okay guys what is going on welcome to
punch truck sports we start a little
late because our guest today will be
Danish in a Neal Ryan O'Neal is here
with me right now I will be discussing
the big fight that's coming up that we
will hello everybody how are you and so
we start a little late cuz we're waiting
for Jeff and fight money oh we should be
breaking news breaking news Brent bill
comes coming in there's a well another
school shooting this guy with the school
shooting news always breaking the news
is that your main thing is you won't you
won't deliver any other news unless it's
a school shooting yeah okay
so they'll be popping in whenever they
get here but welcome to punch some
sports never had on me
I had no we had a super fun time in
skank fest in New York we had the best
time ever
so thanks to everybody to put that
together big Jay and Christine they did
a hell of a job Ari Shaffir
Ari Shaffir I can't think of any other
people pretty much already did it yeah
Ari big Jay Christine I think was a main
lugisu Gomez which we found out that's
true he did have a small hand in that
small hand and Dave yeah so it was super
fun so shout out to everybody that came
out and hung out with all of us they did
a lot of hard work that was a lot of
work they put in another thing I was
impressed I was too man it was but it
was weird being trapped in that building
for like two days straight yeah you did
kind of feel like being on a cruise ship
like the worst cruise ship ever after a
while yeah it started to have like a
like another day of that would have been
like being in Vegas for a long time yes
you know you're in Vegas for one extra
Daniel oh this sucks it was the perfect
amount of time but it's absolutely
perfect 1:00 a.m. rolled around on
Sunday go I gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here I gotta go I can't take this
anymore yeah another one more day of
that would have been like well you kind
of would have started to go crazy yeah
cuz you're there for the whole time so
it kind of becomes like just your world
it's like you're there for like 12 hours
and their shows constantly yeah I mean
hire time every about every two hours I
did a show of some sort
either you're a guest on somebody's
podcast or you're doing your own podcast
or you're doing the stand-up pop-up on
I did Jeremiah showed to stand up on the
spot I did that one you know sir I saw
you do another one in the basement where
you were screaming at people shut the
[ __ ] up
oh that was fun all I hear is madman
haha scream I blew my voice that was a
weird room because there was a kind of a
room and then there was a bar at bar
above the room and she like this but
I've gotten bumped somehow like so many
times by this one lady and I was the
only person I really had a problem with
and there were people she was cool
though I liked that lady I think she
just had a lot on I don't [ __ ] a lot on
her plate but well I was arguing with
her was that like she was putting a lot
of these comics up there that were just
whatever just local New York comics they
were there to get a spot in and I had
like four or five people that were there
they were like we're gonna take a train
back to Connecticut but they only had
like that one day pass yeah and that was
Saturday or Sunday whatever Sunday was
when I lost my voice and Sunday was when
I lost my virginity well congratulations
well I would love to hear about that and
so in that and I'm like these people
paid $150 each to come see our podcast
and like but they haven't seen me do
stand-up yet like can't you throw me up
now because you're looking at eight
hundred dollars with a ticket yeah you
know what I mean and I'm part of the
reason they came all the way from
Connecticut and they have to leave and
if there's one piece on there that was
at least sixty percent of the crowd
dude I would have doubled him down that
room was like dead that night yeah it
was super late and then so I fight then
they she doesn't so then I still do my
spot and now there's five people in the
room and it's 30 people in the [ __ ]
bar and you can't hear [ __ ] and I'm
salty I'm so mad salty are you were
you're a little beyond salty right so I
took the mic in mic stand into that bar
into that bar and just laid into all of
those [ __ ] people you know I mean and
then I took it back to the small bar in
front of five people and it was totally
quiet for a minute and then I was like
dating is weird right guys like right
back this rates rate your pro right
there and then it got loud again and
and I'm I just try my blood started
boiling again and I said to this guy
give me anything you want me to call
this any kind of name and he goes
[ __ ] which is a classic go to these
days old like what you see what the
neighborhood killer scallywag
you see the baby I think it's a
[ __ ] yeah it's 50s a suburban
America terminology so then I didn't
take the stand this time I just kind of
like covertly walked in the room was so
scared like last time I came in and I'm
like what's the boggle or kept calling
among would say like yeah maybe is that
a good or a bad thing
that's a term my grandmother you see
who's a lot yeah I was a little mad
about that that person looks like a
[ __ ] so wait so the [ __ ] D train
gets in so we can talk about a Yerger
guys pod and your guys big press
conference down so people who aren't
aware of what's going on we've talked
about several times on the show but you
are going to be fighting at ellis mania
yeah another professional mixed martial
artist yes
Louis J go to go man yeah he got that
name for a reason apparently Legion of
skanks now you guys are going to square
it off now what rules because it's an
MMA fight not boxing it is anime but
it's got it there's a few changes no
elbows to the head and no knees to that
but that's it okay and that's it which
is yeah which definitely handicaps me
but as I've said before I've given him
everything he's wanted because he cries
when I don't give him when I when I push
back on anything he he gets a little
little pissy it's not worth dealing with
yeah so you're and how confident are you
about in this fight I'm very confident
yeah I mean do you is there any part of
you that's like man I could get caught I
could cuz we're ahead but we're in
headgear yeah not gonna lie it's not
gonna a lot of knockouts with headgear
you know what though headgear just make
sure had a bigger target you still can
get knocked out pretty easily
and now you can kick to the head you can
kick to them but I don't think he has a
capability of doing come on sue I know
but I'm hey guys lookie lookie look so
we were having a debate on I don't even
know if we should bring it up earlier oh
well yeah because we were concerned
about was before the show started guys
everybody welcome the DJ Jeff the Danish
Dennis what some fight mommy we're not
talking about the oh you're fine we get
it but we were just saying what you guys
may want to do with the baby we were
worried you know if you leave it in the
car to leave the air conditioning going
the car no windows the windows are fine
that's that's and then we were like yeah
because you don't want to run out of gas
gas prices are insane right and then you
might not have enough gas to get home
then we thought what if somebody steals
your radio cuz your windows are cracked
throw the keys in the car with the baby
windows up keys in the car with the baby
run lock the door in case you guys get
out running case you guys get robbed
when somebody steals your keys and then
they find your car and the baby's in
there right we put a key we put a club
on the car seat so no we're gonna get
the baby but radio is dispensed that we
it's expendable in this whole operation
yeah yeah okay so you definitely said
yeah I guess somebody hasn't looked at
the price of car stereos lately yeah so
keys in lock the doors windows up you're
only gonna be any like three hours yeah
and what's it and we said what it's like
88 now what's the most is gonna get up
to 91 92 maybe 87 if there's a good
breeze with the baby of the desert you
got it you know it's a climatic life is
hard yeah that early life is hot yeah
it's gonna be yes and then what you do
is you also put camouflage over the baby
so if somebody's walking by yeah can't
see that you've left the baby in the car
with the window maybe just like a bunch
of blankets over the baby we also put a
bear trap right near the kid carrot so
like if you reach your arm in you're
gonna get your arm ripped off that was
smart
yeah that's just goddamn good parenting
right yeah that's not yes we're
listening at home that's a that's a
parenting hack yeah take that and it's
just
you're pregnant you're gonna have your
first baby or something write this down
write all this down of the six women
listening I heard you guys had some
women fans at skank fest it was pretty
crazy
they walked out on the show like one by
one they were all leaving I know
was it not what I think I think it was
more of a protest I think they were
protesting I don't think they were fan
it was a for women March they're like
we've seen enough I had two different
african-american gentleman come up to me
and say I'm your one black listener so
you both are they need to fight you can
only have one yeah I thought about
Johnson who wasn't there he's the og bi
he wasn't there yes so that's at least
three hey Johnson the fighter no I'm
only one black fan away from be able to
use the n-word I think well I think
that's for black fans I don't know that
around town technically in the state law
how many do you need five I think so
yeah okay we drop and Bob you're like I
don't have friends but I have listeners
so that's I mean I relate to him in some
ways without some sort of statute would
people are like yeah you drop in Bob's
with black guys gonna punch you you're
like legally hang on sir is Anthony
Johnson still a big WM be a guy that was
his yeah I think that's because one he
likes basketball so why not works like
to his his daughter plays and he coaches
his daughter and I think she kind of got
him into it that's nice he's fan of your
guys too you know it uh yeah I've met
him we hang out
you've met it yeah we swim together
[Laughter]
Johnson that lesbian that that's Mac
hard hey Sammy
hey Sammy I wanna move to mooch OH
put Ronda Rousey's Clinton armbar fella
you sure made the Hall of Fame I want to
make her ah laughing okay so wait we're
talking about your fight and Mac hard
might be the opening fight on that car
that could be it is what your punch yeah
that's the name of it right uh-huh
Mont your punch they did a survey really
maybe they can get the comic Monge to
a little opening yeah oh we were talking
earlier by the way booty shot clock was
very upset data you were working with
Tony last night
well I'm sorry Boone yeah I apologize
why'd he tell him oh yeah but he did say
well he better do something cuz he has
to pay child support if there's a father
in your life he's just out of the
[ __ ] picture no parenting whatsoever
he's actually watching the baby out by
the car right now oh wait oh that's a
yeah these guys have a bathtub I know it
was very upset last night that uh you
never have a bad luck would have it we
put it though why come you never have a
bathtub good question why come don't you
and then he goes nobody here that's a
bad bucket why can't they put one in the
main room green room
what are you shower in there yeah why
not about somebody well really Boone
people problems tell me that the water
pressure they did something about the
place shut the water off on the opposite
it was like too much strong they was a
fire hose yeah I would love to shoot
bribed the police getting him out of
there sprang up down the sidewalk he was
on last night yeah two cop cars show up
you know they probably called the cops
when somebody drunk or whatever but the
two cop cars pull up and then boom goes
to me I'm saying I'm fronting he goes
here for me because my taxes did he run
to hide such high priority and they come
to him in person file taxes Oh where's
out cowling I need to get out of here
fifteen this is they're coming back when
I was the CEO fifteen shirts in two
years that's $15 well much do I hope for
that how they send the police to
oh they found them oh oh that
helicopters for me bathtubs in prison
hey Mike uh he would know do you guys
see the Undercover Boss with Boone on it
where he was he works with the guys who
were stealing t-shirts and yet a
disguise I'm actually your boss I've
always wanted to see do one of those see
what those hundred cover bosses but it's
like at Burger King but it's just the
big Burger King guy with that dumb hat
but he says I have your cover a stupid
big fake mustache
he already has a mustache they clean
shave in the crown was wearing one of
those Jamaican hats with the dreads then
come on exactly but it's like super big
where's our easy uh oh that's a great
point
wait hold on see if we're all gonna take
a guess at what is auto-reply yeah I do
I saw I know oh yes all right so I can't
take you guys can both gasp sir
because I know group text how are you in
on this no no you showed me I showed him
us it was an email it's a magnet you
don't have it you can take anything you
want on here actually that couch would
look great uh this a magnet Aaron can I
put it on some of the computers doesn't
coaster though right put it right on one
of the computers it's the oddest thing
ever a magnet that doubles as a coaster
magnet
I knew Ari was gone and I couldn't
recall where but I know he's going to
Edinboro like an after wherever he is
now but I figured he's like out of the
country and some sort of time zone where
in the world is very San Diego so let me
guess what is auto-reply okay go ahead
all I said was hey I don't know where
you are but I think it's some far away
time zone are you gonna be on skype
tomorrow or not it's me nanny and do you
know I'm not I'm not gonna get back to
you cuz you're a loser because I'm
traveling the world you're not just
sitting at home cuz your disgusting slob
and I do board things of you because I
make more buddy not too far yeah very
close to be honest and then if he knows
because we're on it's on us for having a
baby and wasting our lives
I should have known it was an auto-reply
because I got an email back right away
who does the honor of why by the way
yeah like people with legit jobs do it
it's so are you like maternity leave or
like a vacation but are easy I mean
would you say he's a I mean he makes
good money but what is he a legit
businessman I mean no well let's see
yeah after you hear this so basically
are you gonna be there Tanis no Neal and
me and nany here's a reply I'm hiking in
the Alps Oh until July 25th it's not
that I don't want to help you figure out
solutions to your problems it's more
than that it's much more than I
prioritized Mountain yodeling over
reading emails if this message fills you
with any level of jealousy that's not my
intent
however I would look at that jealousy as
a signs travel more see the world
flights are far cheaper than you'd
expect in almost any country imaginable
as amazing sites and for is the board
live your life what an uppity cut I like
how he's inspiring via away messages I'm
sure I'm sure yeah yeah but are they
they kind of are but they can aren't
it's actually a great [ __ ] thing have
this cut the inspirational Otto why you
guys just have your newest punch-drunk
t-shirt it's a little long but yeah
we'll be inspired I think that's a punch
honk tattoo classic re right there
classic art and I like everyone who's
hitting him up have problems I know I
don't know it's particularly I retire my
king II but I prioritize hiking over
helping you with your dumb problem and
yodeling I didn't know Ari could yodel I
would love to see that you know he's
doing it like but like taking it very
seriously with his shirt off
yeah those dumb [ __ ] sneakers and his
shirt off
it was so funny we were at skank fest
like everybody was outside like lined up
for shows or smoking or whatever and
I'll just hear this bell ring like a
little gay bike Bell Bing Bing and then
you look in there it goes shirtless ari
I'm one of those bikes you can rent
was he wearing his Swiss Alps at
everybody was like [ __ ] you yeah
have one of those Ricola I mean I'm in
this wit I'm a professional yodeler now
I've left comedy notes all have been
doing there's a yodeling so skank fest
you guys show was great we were all at
it there's a lot of fun a lot of fun you
guys had the press conference for the
fight we did earlier if anyone wants to
see video go to Danish snow Neil our
patreon is how he put it up keep it up
see for $1 hmm that's a good deal that
is a good deal great deal because the
visual if you love the audio you are
going to be hilarious I was there for
the whole day wasting chairs like one of
the greatest that was so funny and then
the [ __ ] the rattlesnake of like 15
people was so great
what if you you hear us call him fat why
not see for your own eyes how fatty you
yeah and his sunglasses you got to see
it all and I believe he was on acid
during that was he uh he he take an acid
the night before yeah yeah most most
training fighters do yeah I talked to
chuck liddell and he was always on acid
a month before a fight wasn't he doing
shrooms later that day to Chuck Liddell
I think oh he may have been yeah so a
micro dosing yeah so yeah I think this
is also I was like I'm just gonna take
half a tab yeah see that's that's he
shows he's taking it seriously half he's
cutting back I like when he said that
the pounds are just coming off with
these he said he can drop it whenever
you want or he goes why do you choose to
walk around why don't you live your life
this is your fear guru you should all be
yodeling right now this is re Robbins
sounds like a guy who's making money off
Winnie the Pooh tonisha fear sounds like
a legit guy who would do that sounds
like a Vegas like performer oh you're
all losers peeler you sir you big fat
piece of [ __ ] you owe yourself when's
the last time you were in Austria
flights are way cheaper than yours right
now shut up [ __ ] you the loser right
there I hate you what's your question is
the highest suicide rate of any
motivational speech he motivates you to
kill yourself that's all a bit of
walking across hot coals we're gonna dip
you in hot matzo ball soup we're gonna
go take a spits in New York how many
times did he say spits when we were
there 70 maybe he's getting ready for
his Jewish hour special I so did
Schmidt's though and it was pretty good
really yeah describe this whole process
to me you just go in it's this Russian
Turkish bathhouse uh-huh already sounds
gay
sounds like a place where you could get
your dick sucked by a man and then also
shanked no live your life I like to do
both it was like that was that Eastern
Promises where I'd viggo mortensen
gets [ __ ] shanked in there like a
naked fighter like right yeah that's
good it was basically we're just trying
to Schmidt some people are [ __ ]
O'Neill hid behind our he's balls he
avoided the gunfire probably good place
to get shade we should throw that at the
baby in the car too but ours balls Oh
his ball sack you know what we're great
that would be a great an Ari Shaffir Sun
Visor for your windshield but it is nut
sack that's good or sorry driver side
ones way bigger and the passenger side
why does it one still can get in why
doesn't mr. live your life oti live your
life why does he do truck nuts of his
actual balls thank you Ari Shaffir truck
or or kettlebells ah kettle balls in
Rogen could plug absolutely I bet he
could live your life I'm now selling
merch xxx
you know instruct us to just be dragging
the whole time I'm too big one there
like your truck needs be lifted more
baby
ones just constantly bouncing on the
concrete the other ones just kind of
dangling upstairs it would cause a lot
of potholes in the roads you imagine if
they actually fell off of your car and
then hit the car behind you would kill
somebody it's like a baseball and a
[ __ ] ping-pong ball I have a lawsuit
I'm going to Thailand I'm living my life
again oh I got a [ __ ] pregnant I
don't know that Oh first of all just
wanna let you know I will never read
this this is girlfriend email them and
get the same response I guarantee it
I guarantee it Hostel have you guys met
her I did meet her you met her we find
that also he enjoys me yeah he wouldn't
introduce we had to introduce myself
why would I introduce you to hurt you're
a loser because I know but you
introduced her to run as easy he's been
on TV he's already said it's so nice to
his friends that was his motivational
speaking who's trying to motivate you
yeah motivated you to get on TV
yeah and instead you're fighting a
[ __ ] pocket mare was she was she
asking fest she showed up it was
Saturday night I'm so mad at him shut up
Sunday night at for the second roast bad
oh yeah after rallies the killed one no
no ZZ weiner madam and then saws dick
minutes later no it saw his dick first
then met him oh that's cool yeah so yeah
that's I'd rather go that way I'd rather
you see my snacks and then read me
I love watching Ari interact with women
that he's involved it's like it's
interaction with a stranger is it it's
still that awkward they've been together
like a year you said on the show there's
a batteries they look okay let's go God
look you feel like dancing are you
hungry
is he nice to her really big puncture
twice sir is there any ice in the
freezer
nothing better was him and his first
wife we watch it oh did you turn the
heat down to like 75 which probably look
as if you did she's nice but ya know his
new ladies that is how she sounded yeah
okay I got what happened with you and
your wife she moved away no I don't
think so their deploy no father say yeah
he's living his life she's living her
life she moved to Hawaii she got a plane
they're both living there yeah by the
way if you're already living your life
ignore this auto-reply stop reading now
what if you're on a plane you could
delete this email yeah if you've got a
cheap ticket and your flag somewhere a
few yodelling if you're on your way to
yodel you got away to yodel classic noir
this is the event if you're in Austria
I'm on trail 7 it's a Black Diamond hike
I'm plowing moment out he's snow plowing
the entire hike with his ex-wife from
Mirim Miramar Myanmar the children he
took the picture with the Hitler
mustache that wasn't really good yeah
he's still facing touchable yeah I think
he's like feeding most of them he also
gives some motivational talk it's like
you guys are all losers because you're
aborted third-world countries they're
all carrying it I understand you can't
help but not live your lives you can't
afford to live your lives but you're
still losers it's [ __ ] you're the
world's smallest Sherpas get my bag just
watch band throws keys at him I'll be
living my life
[Laughter]
that did watch him do his new hour the
Jew that's great yeah we wrote some rent
both you guys I thought it was really
good I didn't see it that was it um that
was great how is the bit how is this 10
minutes on could filter fish gefilte
larious
it felt great you talk about poram
Jewish Halloween I don't think he did he
talk about Christianity much more and
then he gets into some of his the
crazier side of yeah it's all religion
yeah yeah perfect for the most part you
know there's a little it's like 80% but
he says but [ __ ] about probably also
he's gonna be pissed he's like how dare
you reveal some of my bits everybody
seen the new hour yeah he's gonna stop
living his life to yellow well I mean it
had thinking you do that while he lives
his life the sky poem from the Austrian
why are you calling
I was killed Tony last night you guys
would judge I got there right when you
guys were pretty much wrapping up it was
good a knack hard was there oh really
I want to eat your [ __ ] Tony Tony I
thought you were a lady that's the
biggest cleared I haven't seen in my
life Tony Mac hard I randomly search
because I was like is this person still
alive yeah we were better we talked
about her pretty often
she gave Perry caravello like the hard
dyke award and I was I laughed out loud
yeah she did a video she was a comic
yeah was she in LA Sammy
there's someone I think she was like
East Coast or something like that no
one's ever seen her and Sam took Tripoli
[Music]
thank you my heart just quit the show me
I gotta go so by the way after we after
we all of the crazy drama that we've had
on this show the last month and whatnot
and Sam quitting and if you listen to
the skank fest show he had a big
farewell speech at the end of it and all
this I run into Sam last night at the
comedy star and I'm here to report he
will be back early August which is
basically next week so he took a month
to three episodes but for a month
been talking about how he quit and how
and of that episode ii was like the
whole show was over like he was speaking
for all of us like he's like don't worry
we will be back yeah I was confused I
was no one told me was he like he's just
like punch-drunk will survive a real
dream and then I see and he's like I
think I'll come back in August like well
they're great there you go what's wrong
try to figure out is it my my condom
[ __ ] I can barely hear myself in real
life I don't know well that might be a
hearing oh this one's yours to your
vibes there I'm just carrying that thing
started like hitting me in the leg and I
thought it came unplugged oh no it's
just the the babies crawling around the
floor must have pulled it out yeah yeah
yeah oh you let that thing out of the
car yeah she got out I saw that you
looked and saw her and was shocked that
she is actually I don't you know I just
thought you guys are good being better
parents than that and just would have
left it in the car keys I suppose
exposing her for this foul language and
filthy man whatever he cusses in front
of her like outside of the podcast role
he's like I'm so sorry and then we're
like do seems like where we bring her
like how we speak yeah a couple people
it's gang fest apologize didn't be
written like that green room secluded we
were like yeah also do you think a
four-month-old is just gonna be like
[ __ ] no I do not want to picture
that
I mean I think you are he has a weird
like sweet side if no one's around and
no one's looking no I don't want to
expose them too much but he's really
sweet with her off off air he fetch it
she liberalize what cities has she been
to she has been to a lot of states rere
would ya press there this is all in
country go go international when she
goes to Israel without view Bing dude I
would love a [ __ ] like candid video
of re just like a loan in the [ __ ]
alpine forests but yodeling just jerking
off the whole time in yodeling just
sitting indian-style oh I call it
meditating he shits on the ground then
smells it throws it at himself because
there's no one to plate he's playing
goofs on himself I got I got me with
that one
well played well played indeed think
he's headed to Montreal though yeah you
should fear travels he's got an ex-monk
season he goes in New York for 12 hours
then it goes right to Montreal so he's
gonna he's gonna right he's gonna fit
for to go to the pickle factory to get
some of his favorite kosher Dill's
uh-huh he's like he's like a yo-yo
low-dollar yodeler yolo doe-eyed more yo
little you know you know what I saw by
the way right before I got here is
someone sent it to me on Twitter Pauly
Shore
Pauly Shore sent out a tweet I'm in
Israel bro looking for people to hang
out with I'm with my friend Dean then he
put the eyes the emoji picture of the
Argentinian flag you think you ran it by
deed is this the right flat bro is this
the right flag what a great combo he
didn't paulien israel bro this hummus is
great oh yeah that that's not gonna end
well
I'm wheezing the hummus yeah did he it's
like what it's like that it
you know yes does that ton of nothing
the dead bro right when I first was well
not even first at the store but when
Duncan took over for princess Cori right
yeah who is actual royalty for actual
royalty and I'm as Town Grenadier and
then they're like hey you want to be
doing one worked a lot I was like mmm
the sweet offer I do not want to work
the law how could you resist I was like
I'd be a door gap I wouldn't bit dude a
lot I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] somebody's
car up I don't want that basic $30 for a
month
you ever seen David Taylor play bumper
cars and they put a couple of times I
didn't want to be that guy I know what
I'm capable of and plus there's no way
you can like [ __ ] around
if the lot guy you're a door guy that's
what you can still kind of [ __ ] off you
can disappear you can't disappear if
you're doing a lot not really and so I
was like Nano and do that and then he's
like well the only other thing is you
guys are gonna get a kick out of this is
paulie's looking for like a punch-up
rider and someone to help him with this
[ __ ] I got I'll do that and I didn't
know Paulie for two positions our lock
guy or we have this other less desirable
position just punch up writer from no
clue what I was get myself into is good
option yeah really it's like you can go
[ __ ] yourself or you can take a [ __ ]
[ __ ] can I do both at the same time I
could have so then I'm you know talking
to him and then he would go liked it so
I'm gonna email you a bunch of my like
ideas right and then he would I would
get an email I am not joking you guys I
would get an email that just was like a
bullet point
first of all typos through that the
wing-wang like you'd been typing boxing
gloves on without where they all do they
all have Argentinian flag I got this new
bit about living your life right so you
got so it would just be like a bullet
point and then it would just say
airplanes leaves a lot to work with I
was like oh this is like giving you
artistic freedom the movie planes stole
Polly's idea and
and then did like but it's like a bus in
the air now so then exactly what I've
never once even called an air bus so I
go to UM so then I would have to go
watch him do sets and for the most part
they were only at the store sometimes I
have to go the Laugh Factory whatever
they were always stuck when I would do
that but and then I would just watch his
[ __ ] and I would actually took it kind
of seriously briefly and then I would
give him like you know a bullet point
like real good tags and stuff like that
and then go watch him verbatim like he
did it the first time like just I was
literally working fed baggies killing
bro that's exactly what I'm looking for
that's exactly what did the job yeah
we're coming up on 16 years now there's
only one way to live your life guys and
I think that we know what it is maybe
maybe like half a year and then I went
to doing I'm like this is like it's
almost feels like I'm in trouble like
I'm grounded like I have to just go
watch is that and nothing happens from
it like every time I would give him
anything you would never do it you know
I was going on the road with him or
anything should you start to give him
crazy [ __ ] when I first met him we're
after that moment when I first met him
and I love Pauly's and I've always been
nice to me but when I first when I first
met him I was like went to go talk to
her about the job and first thing you
said to me is like did some make me
laugh bro that's wrong like in the up
straight to-the-point his office way up
there like it's a make me laugh and I'm
just like a soft-shoe number on your
desk [ __ ] bro what if Dean Gelber
joins the Mossad Israel's top yeah what
if they both that would be the greatest
thing ever
what if they both smell another my
parents but if they both get like get
that in the Mossad now Pauline Gilbert
oh I see that movie Dean's mom best joke
ever that you guys
had was when you guys were doing the
roast of Dean in the left and Tommy
Morris as well yeah that was the best
and I you go uh-huh what is it what is
it what's what is very her dreams Lainey
Lainey yeah they got hey know that he's
leaving you have to pay your tab
and it went like audience like a fifty
it just kept scrolling down maybe
milking three drinks oh by the way I
don't need to talk about this yeah you
know Jimmy and Joey comedy royalty from
the car yeah there's a new one
there's a new Jimmy but I learned last
night that at won't so if you don't know
these people are ownio and I well it's
just I think your boy a handful of
people are listening they don't know we
we open mics with these fools wow they
were too or they half-greek but they
were brothers yeah two brothers original
take technically Dimas and Dante are
their real names that's true we found it
on their checks and started calling it
they didn't like it shockingly Wow
but Joey is the main guy he was like
what Boone loves to get called of Floyd
Charles Djou Cornelius Cornelius Jimmy
was the brains behind the operation but
he had a real job selling aluminum
siding or something he laughs okay
and Joey he looks like a miniature Tony
Danza Joe has carried the act on his
small back for years yeah 18 years long
and he's just gone through like 10 Jimmy
even these are named Jimmy fat James if
you know that he was one of them yep
so I heard last night at one point he
had a puppet and he's gonna act told me
no really yeah he's like he at one point
he couldn't find a guy so he just made a
puppet and he was doing the act but he's
also he was the least talented even when
he brought in other people he was always
so now yes not only be a ventriloquist
yes if I could do the [ __ ] himself
I would pay top dollar to watch this
[ __ ] come on my nose why I said the
rich last night like I would some kind
of get it if like these bits were likely
the best thing you've ever seen him give
everybody a little example this there's
good to like Italian guys and they
played a room meatball Goomba character
but give him some of the jokes well I do
Italian say Jehovah's Witnesses cuz
Italians don't like any witnesses that's
Italian dice at one point said he goes
you can't use the oh that's my thing and
then they'd to do act without and they
were helpless without the Foley artists
funny without the bunks and the bomb
they did sing too they had a song a rap
yeah rap Oh like I do remember that the
we like pasta pasta sauce would worry
the kitchen were the boss I got a big
dick between my legs
oh we love these guys at one point he
threatens me he threatened my life
which one well Jimmy was this one he
last years ago because he knew that I
was dragging him down I was walking
through the hall about I don't know a
couple Monday's ago right before the
week we went to skank fester that Monday
and he was there and I'm like and I
haven't seen him for probably four or
five years is this Joey
both Joey put the new Jim okay it's hard
to keep track
yeah my god I in my head I'm like oh you
got another one like your back like
every time you get to I watch the ricky
grubs fitness face he's walked away I
want to do a document that's Italian
I want a documentary called finding
Jimmy it's about this it really would be
good just go through these [ __ ] like
20 different guys I can I can easily
think of the four four or five yeah and
I didn't even know about the puppet god
I would love to if there was one we had
like a normal guy who's kind of jacked
you remember that him the one guy
threatened you yeah that was the guy who
I was in the back heckling when they got
off and I
crying laughing so hard at the threat
and they're like awarded you this is
your last warning
okay guys like we could breathe I was
laughing there was a new Jimmy so we
decided to welcome on the town throw him
ugly and so he brought him up and O'Neal
me and I believe Skippy sign my Skippy
had the best he just kept yelling talk
about lasagna yo Joey who's great quick
off-the-cuff say what you want about him
he just kept saying he wouldn't attack
Skippy because he was a paid regular at
The Comedy Store we weren't at the time
and he just kept saying Ryan [ __ ]
O'Neal [ __ ] it was brutal it was it was
brutal and the Jimmy guy said that's
never gonna happen again okay guys I
think I said that we probably will that
angry Jimmy out of all the different
Jimmy's and then fat James was Jimmy for
a while well I think some of these
Jimmy's get there and then Joey sells it
is like I'm a regular at The Comedy
Store of all these things and then he
gets in there and realizes he's a
laughingstock and then these these
Jimmy's figure it out you know how could
he when you run in lines with these TVs
illusion oh you mean the one I wrote a
book
it's paperback it's called shoving up
your ass by the way I don't want to yeah
I feel like I'm exposing a lot of their
material I think all these materials
copy written by Joe they should live
their lives and go back to Italy Oh
jeepers than you think
all this material could be fine on the
Internet where they [ __ ] be on it
what are some of their owners babe what
were some of their other [ __ ] they had
[ __ ] did a Paris Hilton I wish I saw the
goddamn puppet dude I'm die I wish I
hope it comes back even like whoa oh oh
let's see what it looks like what it's
something about oh I bought it a new
parish wherever they go or whoever I go
daigo yeah it was his Italian shoes I
like Italian shoes yeah Oh get some act
out Stu they go why do I tell you guys
always have their shoulders up I don't
[ __ ] know oh one was out we went to
Disneyland we don't like it cuz Mickey's
are rad that's why he's got three
fingers
everyone knows that mob guys do stand-up
John Gotti was a great New York standard
Mickey Mouse is about have you seen it
in the [ __ ] title
I've never there were times where they
would compose half hours a second to
none yeah it was it's up there when they
would kill it would drive me crazy like
I wanted to light the room on fire to
prevent people from believing I'm nice
uncle I saw it
he happened I once brought I had I had
Tommy forced my hand to bring them up
when I was hosting once so I gave him
like a four minute introduction about
how these guys inspired me a dark comedy
these guys are the people the reason why
I'm here these guys are genius they went
up the crowd [ __ ] hated him so much
and then he gave Joey a big hug I did I
gave a hug me like trying to push me off
you guys had a powwow cuz he O'Neal was
saying didn't want to put him up they
bitched at Tommy Tommy [ __ ] - Dean up
the ladder yeah and I went to the back
hallway and he's like bro you gotta do
it and Joey standing there not such a
push up I came over and started talking
some side [ __ ] and Joey looked up at
make these four foot tall he goes excuse
me and I go excuse me I don't like you
and I go it's very mutual you can just
straight-up tell someone to their face I
don't like you and people like I get it
I really like you used to paint the
numbers on curves they might still do
that I don't know hey here's an address
I can't barely read it if you were to go
over there tomorrow I'm dying to see
this puppet got it I want to know which
which Jimmy it looks like if it looks
like his brother I think fat J I think
it's a recently dead Italian guy he
should just had fat James stuffed when
he died what wheeled about there that'd
be a heavy prop that's true
you know forklift I want Jim painter to
join the act
Italian woman's [ __ ] smell so [ __ ]
bad I don't know as Joey let's do the
rap why do Italians love Italian buffet
because their big fat [ __ ] dude I sir
he's not doing it man I have a [ __ ] why
didn't nobody why don't you always find
out find out a goddamn email chain that
hey this guy's doing a pump attack come
check it out I didn't go one further if
anybody switches it up to a puppet act I
think that needs to be a [ __ ] ape
he's gone done a suitcase for it
probably I bet here like a miniature
like a bunch of stickers of like this oh
the Italian flags and carbon monoxide
poisoning is he online just look up
Jimmy and Joey on YouTube and you'll
find in comedy that's probably they have
a website there the meatballs the comedy
is what they call that is true that
meatballs a comedy that's and they do if
you read their website it says they have
like a feature film in the works of
course and the TV show yeah oh wow
because I've looked at it a long time
ago I was like it sounds like they're
living inside just look your life quit
your job come on kill yourself oh you're
so first thank you come to Austria gog
pope puppet kill him fake your death and
then coming off it's weird though Ari
has kind of wierd stances I could see
him being like Jimmy and Joe at least
he's trying he's trying new things he's
adventurous normally other people you
know that there'll be a random person
that you'll think he'll totally agree
with everyone's view on this person and
be like at least you try yeah yeah yeah
he's expressing himself artistically
he'll be dead in a year
oh but at least he's trying can I bring
up to sports topics absolutely
one how about the Mets pitcher getting
foot-and-mouth disease what happened I
did watch Noah syndergaard his foot and
mouth disease of a disabled where's he
from
I he got it because he went to something
like kids sports camp and I guess those
dirty kids really gave me old
foot-and-mouth oh my god they say as an
adult if you get it it's really bad yeah
really like what what happened nobody
has it it's very rare yeah yeah so this
guy who calls himself Thor he's got long
you know I don't know yeah yeah so he's
on the DL with what what I'd like some
of the side effects are what loving are
you worried you by now no I'd solve all
my problems
yeah that's why I can't live my life I
got goddamn foot-in-mouth disease maps
didn't read it didn't the league have an
outbreak of foot-and-mouth onset and I
think a bunch of the crew who like his
foot in his mouth all the time mouth is
terrible did they really
Trey I remember it yeah they did have an
out cuz like somebody's kid got it at
school and that went through the whole
quiz is it common for kids
I do not haven't heard they say kids can
get it and it's not as bad but when
adults get it the symptoms were way
worse they said that's how like
chickenpox are like it's very dangerous
to have that as an adult and as a kid it
just blows right through it so you get a
rash I think on your feet and your mouth
that's the hence the footnote huh but
they just said it's like very painful
and just not yeah but not on your wiener
so you can still [ __ ] yeah yeah
definitely yeah yeah yeah dick and [ __ ]
that's the worst I've had that before no
gross we've all had a few rounds of that
I've had since dick and [ __ ] disease
for a long time and then second topic is
Jimmy Garoppolo the 49ers quarterback
captain handsome he days dating a porn
star oh yeah yeah well he's been seeing
our she's got some gigantic fun bangs no
way
I know but yeah it's your small tits
though are now because there's so many
big tits small tits are now coming back
the plate over saturated the market
boobs which I didn't think was possible
like I got a tiny tits and a huge [ __ ]
yeah instead of the classic huge big
tiny puss yeah live your life if you
need a giant [ __ ] I don't care whose
living a life beside I want someone
again I'm going spelunking in her [ __ ]
uh where's my mining cap would the
doctor give you just one detour canary
in there first
if you had an a-cup what a doctor just
give you one single detail hey I want to
look like I had a single mastectomy yeah
for a goof just one they made a guy look
like a human Kendall and he looks like
he's in pain have you seen this oh my
god like someone's doing those out by
the way he does no no he looks like a
guy no no but he's not even in very good
shape
have you seen him lately okay go I
caught a doughy oh he's Kenneth an adult
you know who looks I was shocked at how
this guy looks Joey's puppet the Joey's
puppet dude this fat [ __ ] Italian
piece of [ __ ] no the UH one of the guys
from calling me bad got into a fight and
like they're doing like rinky-dink
[ __ ] like what shows they used to
stay singing that song but there's only
three of them right and it's like
they're one of them look like Kenny G
not that one not that one how many did
there used to be those slices for up I
think there was one black guy no black
guys oh no black guys and let's keep it
that way right America no but man so so
three of them are sync now and it's like
a [ __ ] kind of a faraway video was
like on TMZ like yesterday can't far
away video but they're in like a [ __ ]
looks like a high school gym like
they're doing like a rinky-dink like
little like a sock hop
people are sporadically around it's not
like a standing-room-only kind of a
thing maybe there's a couple hundred
people like a local fair or something
there but it's like a high school
gymnasium or something sounds like we
can get foot-and-mouth go through a
great place to get foot-in-mouth so
three of them are dancing and whatever
and then the song entities like the
like thank you very much you know
whatever [ __ ] city say thank you
Riviera middle school the fourth guy who
wasn't even up there performing with
them cause he's so blasted drunk comes
in and [ __ ] slams up dude that's an
thank you to the ground
really really pushes I'm super hard hey
maybe they had a disagreement and then
he gets arrested for that yeah sounds
like the reunion is going well oh but
he's crazy fast he's so fat he walks
with a cane
really Oh Suze misses some toe that's
why he's not doing it that's why he's
not doing the old [ __ ] like no please
no at this point I'm just hanging up
it's rape I'm just doing the slow jam
you like bring out his beach chair so I
can sit down like you like who's this
fat [ __ ] I was the only guy I've ever
seen perform on a beanbag
look like a bouncer or security or
something I smell a new Joey Jimmy
Jimmy's where do you apply for that
because I'd like to apply all right uh
new Jimmy calm yeah I'm with him you
show up and there's all just greasy
Italian guys in a room waiting but
Ruby's getting just regular white guys
too but I think he needs a black guy I
think you honestly have to be named
Jimmy
he needs a no there was a game oh yeah
oh he changes your name committed you
are to become his brother illegal 75% of
though were genuinely named and you have
to wear to like wife beaters with like a
spaghetti sauce on it
[ __ ] I could see them in a kitchen like
that he needs you there a woman Jimmy or
a black guy just go that would be good
go against the grain yeah it's like when
they made like the Green Lantern black
all of a sudden you know I mean like a
different superheroes are Santa Claus
he's black black is foxy lack of [ __ ]
did you ever do his show and they had
that the river bottom and right net
across the street from Warner Brothers
who's Jimmy Joey no show I don't
remember water bottle you know is the
king of the ocean where on Melrose no no
I'm bad Oh Rose Oh our Barham here
yeah out here no I never did I know
exactly the clip are you talking about
gross cackles the king of the valley
shows he's the king of all those crazy I
didn't show in a long beach the other
night it was he there oh yeah just
hanging out I'm trying to get some [ __ ]
give me some distance brother I think he
was he was the guy that looked like
psychic energy he's got some old photos
it look like Kenny G I want to look up
this fat guy in Color Me badd oh yeah
where's Johnny when you need him I can't
look up at this just Google like I know
Color Me badd or rested or something
like that it's only like a 30-second
video but if you watch the video he
really does slam this guy down hard so
he looks like you might know hi you
might know he just daughter dudes like
skinny like me still are you sure it
wasn't Luis Gomez yeah Lu Jitsu Gomez
and I'll try to get him to call in or
Skype in today but he's knocking it I
might be might blow might be focused in
my PG might be trying to dial right now
but those big old sausage fingers keep
hitting like three numbers it might be
on acid
he's yelling up in the Austrian that's
Jared from Subway yeah that's him that's
him no yes where to God I got obsessed
with it because I couldn't believe it I
mean he used to be kinda like a George
Michael looking dizzy really 600 pounds
no he's like 12 so he doesn't even sing
he just sits on the side while the other
3 guys sing what will find the video
you'll see the video why is it you
should change it to Color Me fat yeah
but can you watch it on this screen
Johnny Johnny watch Johnny
Superman I know you're watching Johnny
help us where is Johnny today he's where
he's from
no he they said that to me when I had
the baby like they're [ __ ] on me
they're like you know we thought she
would be here but we
see where equipment to the hospital room
I was like not even responding to the
text messages even better that's it down
here the video the middle one what are
their other songs besides that I would
have liked I feel like we would know him
if we heard oh yeah there we go in
Seneca County town town of Tyreese where
exactly we're in a fox
it's where he lives his life oh I live
at the Seneca County these guys toured
for a long time trust me they've been on
several planes give him a break yeah
this would be a kind of guy that Ari
would support like this guy cut him some
slack
he had foot-in-mouth disease but he ate
great advertising this is a local crowd
this town seems great is this Tyreese
there's nothing better than local car
they ripped off through the loop that is
speaking of bananas here we go oh here
we go this is where it's gonna go down
Lucas local news guys gentlemen there's
like 20 people in the audience that
looks Oh shove them from behind
oh that Bobby Kelly it wasn't even out
there during the [ __ ] is that Bobby
Kelly dice eyeglasses
I like there's nobody charged him yeah
you're a zero Adams you pushed your
teammate you did this to yourself
dummies remember when Joe Perry kicked
Steven Tyler off stage make another
situation I was like walking down and
like he was singing and he literally
kicked him off it was pretty recent Joe
Perry stand on an Apple box these are
pretty small
yes apparently sought out so my brother
makes me go to a lot of rock stars book
signings like who's the one Steve Jones
yeah I know who he was but he was so
funny and like now I'm a huge fan he was
a very grumpy mean old man and I was
scared to meet him I was like I don't
know who this guy is he's like mean to
the fans like fans were like you're so
like you're the best what he signed this
he's like I don't sign extra things and
like really get the book yeah he wasn't
taking compliments he was just like
looking at them nodding and like annoyed
and I was like I'm so scared to go up to
this man he's burst so that's how I met
Joe Perry who literally was like up to
my shoulder yeah that's my all of my
family who's like very until that
classic rock has the photo of me and him
in their house and free you know what
our daughters doing right now oh she's
out there beating Joe Perry extra large
that's like the time I saw fraser-smith
great Comedy Store radio personality
love Frasier he went up to the dice man
I think I was working a lot so I could
witness it firsthand and the dice man
comes in and I think the dice man wanted
a little space as he did when he gets
out of his car but for age kind of went
up to I'm too soon and he's like my dice
it is good to see you okay if rate you
see phrase the wheels like okay it's
conversations like up on my your son's
band is doing great
yeah you see phrase like oh [ __ ] I'm not
you dying the boys are gonna make it
yeah okay phrase is that keep that okay
to like 15 minutes ago
40 finally well it is good to see you
that's classic dice lovin to [ __ ] with
people yeah he's like how long is he
gonna stick around look at him trying to
talk to me and I'm giving him nothing
and he keeps doing it he checking me
banned ones dice and Frasier we used to
do a present afraid of anybody hated
people man it is terrible to see who you
are a piece of [ __ ] Frasier living your
life tell me kill me motivational
speaker goin dice like quit smoking or
who's trying to quit everything yeah
every [ __ ] other week he you didn't
know if he was smoking or he wasn't
smoking I once saw him buried an
audience member because he had the
cigarette in his mouth
now back hey you want a light and put a
lighter get that out of my face fool he
always had a cigarette but he never
would light it she just liked it in his
mouth and so this back by the stairs to
go to the belly room so I'm Stan and
there's a stray right there it's like
one of the only places you could get
away with smoking right some stand about
Astrid there's two other people standing
next to me smoking and he's like over in
the kind of like past the stairs but in
the lot talking like Ren is easy and
Duncan and munch people so I put the
sticker tomorrow he's easily 15 feet
away from me and he goes unappreciated
if you didn't like that and I rented ZZ
and then Duncan laughs and he's got a
goddamn cigarette in his mouth
don't do it so I just think he's doing a
goof on me and I go I bet and then I
[ __ ] who is this guy's a zero sure so
get him out of here you'll never perform
here again everybody knows who you are
somebody get my hammer I was like [ __ ]
and then Duncan it's a guy by the way he
smokes for like 40 years
Duncan called me the next day and he
goes buddy like he's really pissed buddy
just if you you'd knock he called that
guy that smoked is
take ready he's good I love our daily
686 him so he's like it just if you come
around just don't talk to Titus if you
see him just go the other way
are you cool with them now [ __ ] super
cool with him now does he remember that
probably not next time I see him and you
guys are talking I'm gonna bring it up
to a member who you want this guy okay
maybe yeah oh I forgot [ __ ] yeah
that's right you're still smoking huh
you're a zero you're the guy that's you
know were those camels that was a girl
my lucky smokes but he um no I'm super
cool with his kids I the band actually
is really good if you haven't seen them
I haven't seen that fresh look they're
[ __ ] pretty goddamn good brows still
rebel they changed their name I believe
yeah Tim and his brother and me I I
always call Mellie rocks no there I
gotta check him out I haven't he's a
great German and other kids great [ __ ]
the boys are in a band together
phenomenal though they were really
ripped dialing I would say it if they
did it dice man's a good drummer
yeah they were on some talk yeah you
know maybe the drum off is that right
yeah okay Arnold on Arsenio him and his
son oh yeah yeah I saw that
I can't do it it's too hot the leathers
it's too hot he pretended I couldn't do
it you got two kids already set up and
Mike like yeah he pretended like yeah
cuz we coincidentally have to live full
drum kits already Mike well I'm holding
the sticks already so I guess yeah give
me a hi-hat hey give me a see a bouncy C
uh so guys here's what I'm gonna bring
up we are trying to put together a thing
for your fight with the Lewis J Gomez at
what today twenty fifth twenty dates the
25th August 25th yeah at in Vegas hard
rock hard rock not the Seneca County De
Lago cuz scene I hope he doesn't push
you down like that
definitely what's the sex em off
especially if your back is turned you're
singing a number of the drunk guy is
when your back is turning it's your
closer at Seneca County's big [ __ ]
cakewalk
he really shove him in the ground are ya
he didn't even expect it he was like
finally I'm getting cheers again it's
been so long I hope the rest of the tour
isn't in jeopardy
uh I'm sure it is the second big show at
Seneca County's cakewalk about what we
want to do is use our good friends of
bet yes I know bet TSI is also a sponsor
of Legion of skanks now yes and they
were at the at the skank fest Betty
Esaias was cool to see those guys and
they should become a sponsor of the
Danish and O'Neill podcast because
basically all we do is talk about
gambling let's make it a it's a gambling
podcast so you got a six in an ace you
say hit me break that poker blackjack is
17 we play roulette Oh either way my
uncle went into the World Series of
Poker this year
wait played it yeah yeah shut up guess
what it costs to get in yeah a real
guess yeah $20,000 10 G's yeah getting
lost it three hours oh god oh god your
uncle how happy was your aunt about that
he's single bad he is now he was a say
you want to give someone 70th birthday
present
oh yeah approve this man's a [ __ ]
hero
my teeth are as big as my balls I just
blew my hamstring out that's what you
get in old you blow your hamstring out
laughing how many people talking back to
dsi but how many people got injured it's
gangster my fans walking with a kid grab
a red band you see him leaving in a
[ __ ] honestly big red band on that K
did a dissipation of something going
wrong already
well I am jealous a cane is a pretty
sweet move I think he had it like a
glass case that he's like all right
debris but it's not a cool cane though
it's like he is wondering like you see
an old lass
yeah yeah like blue and sparkly yeah
yeah it has like a tennis ball at the
bottom uh that's the old person like I
want to see you like a pimp came in like
a [ __ ] yeah crystal ball you can pull
it out it's got a fire in it out of
mahogany or something it's something
with like a [ __ ] eagle head or you
can like twirl it walk in like somewhere
turn on the king but also use it as a
weapon
I said you bring back canes if you
really wants to go high budget I'm a
microphone on top that turns on or just
a microphone as the grip a podcast kay
it's carve it simply were to get a
wireless mic cane where's my assistant
[ __ ] on that he gets hurt rebel crowd
surfing you know something yes somebody
the stage dived onto him yeah and
dislocated his knee yeah that happens a
lot NFL guys a lot of crowd oh yeah a
big one so it's the number one but rent
is easy fills in for me for the
basketball game because not unlike
yourselves were you on the state their
flight as well no he went the night
before I was there tonight oh okay okay
got it
well I got in like an hour before you
guys told us all to come to mr. after
the game start lassic Porto Rican Rena
literally picked our fight they're like
get on this flight do not come we can't
change we're gonna set the game at three
where most of the teams can make sure
all of kill Tony was on our flight with
us except and goddamn kind of jam to was
on your play everybody I just had news
just me and Johnny they perform both
shows on the flight oh yeah I did have
Jeff Richards there was Richards on the
first leg of my flight from Denver oh
really yeah he had luggage was the old
Trader Joe's bag I'm gonna do one like
an old wrinkled but he's got tape in
there and I don't know I didn't want to
know [ __ ] sandwich should I even make
you put that through there just carry
that
we don't need oh the babies crawling out
of the car she's underneath the car we
jacked the car up and put her underneath
it yeah good move that's gonna be the
coolest area yeah yeah yeah but you're
just not sure yeah but you're just
holding with like wow it's pipe yeah but
while it's jacked up you're driving it
in Reverse to roll the miles back so you
can get out was it [ __ ] a Ferris
Bueller really yeah yeah yeah great
Chicago movie guy from town injured all
right guy from come down tour he what
nmcli Balea
mad in the basketball game and he was
hurt so bad that they couldn't even do
their live podcast he couldn't care I
already Terry tore his larynx he can't
speak any I heard he's got a foot in
mouth disease
well that basketball game was very
costly and I in Vietnam ran is easy is
filling in for me because he's already
in New York as we know we've thrown
several bashes at his house he fills in
for me so it's re Sam and rent is easy
because they're playing I'm on a flight
still he tears like his calf muscle guys
before we play I think we should live
our lives lives on three I would like
the sing the national anthem before we
play using yodeling only if you want to
play this game you gotta prove you've
been living your life and you take it a
discounted international flights look
lately are you on mushrooms right now
why does it always start a travel
website for a hill book you I'll tell
you the best trips to take know he leads
the tour you go on a dip with REO he
just parade you but also motivate kids
yeah you're an idiot but you living your
life so I don't know what I think I love
you go anywhere with it it'll be like a
you know and because you're ugly we're
in Austria you can eat the hard-boiled
egg of a face [ __ ] you just trying to
live my life just with my lungs been
dropping a lot more of the
mom's not the [ __ ] lastly I've heard him
like five times that might be Luke
fujitsu influence on him
could be cuz luge it seems not afraid to
throw those out himself
yeah oh I think it's just like a [ __ ]
Brooklyn way yeah I think it's just like
I loved it out there I really romantic
like a romanticized being there to
remind you a little the Midwest kind of
[ __ ] going on and everything will
walkable I was walking I was like
furnishing apartments to my head you
didn't mean like oh yeah make sure you
hit a bathtub boom he'll come over and
live his life my god survive in New York
winter trying to steal and this icy good
question he's doing for that lot I'm
just no body fat I'm just worried about
the city taxes he's so worried about
taxes I mean New York has higher taxes I
imagine Giuliani's after me people be
coming up to me saying things I'm going
to turn the dollar fee hello he always
says like he'll walk up to me instead of
saying hi he desire we always greet me
so what happened what whatever okay oh
it's another great when he always says
he'll just walk up to me first thing he
says I don't know who died I didn't read
the papers today that's a bad day you
got to know who died who's he looking
for I have no night school rivals it's
always celebrity he's obsessed with
celebrity deaths
oh speaking of celebrity deaths you I
believe are going to win this fight and
perhaps kill murder illegitimate I've
always wanted to have one what we're
trying to do is set up with our good
friends at Betty si to actually get a
real official line okay why wouldn't
they have you guys talked to him yeah
uh-huh
we're trying to get him to do it and
there were they on the fence or they're
open trying what we're trying to get is
like what it is and it really does
getting you the two of you to agree on
what you think the line should be okay I
know nothing about gambling by the way
surprise lateness that surprises me if
it was a knife-throwing question I yeah
I'll tell you throwing stars did you
have growing up this dude a lot by the
way I I tried to take some on a plane to
Germany
child I live in your life I hid it in a
washcloth and as soon as I got through
the [ __ ] they stopped they took like
ten of my key oh yeah and the 80 if you
could bring like a man they don't even
shine like not these [ __ ] claw these
talons so I lost about ten of them to
the shirtkin O'Hare Airport security but
they let you keep how many well no I had
the rest at home I knew I took everyone
over to Germany I you go I need some try
to start it is for you I was probably
like seven no one checked your luggage
like you're havin I'm having no one yeah
no I don't think so even if I had said
it my mom probably like last thing you
expect is your seven-year-old dad's
gotta lock it in a [ __ ] suitcase I
lost some good ones on that trip I
imagine you're bringing your flagship
[ __ ] yeah I'm bad with Nazis over
there I gotta have my best [ __ ] you
gotta bring the international collection
those aren't the state sides that's
living your life I travel so we're
talking about trying to get it like
maybe like negative 125 so it's like you
know you got to put down what would Gabe
handicap I mean if I put it at a big
about- gave the gambler I saw gave the
gamblers gave me till I walked up he was
the first person I saw outside watching
UFC fight pass on his phone
I walked up the exact same time in saw
him he was Jan what are you doing on it
in Argentina we were watching fights and
he was rooting for Ally akin to heart
that was his roommate yeah that was it
really
yeah but in New York yeah stayed with
them a bunch of times yeah yeah
bad basically inseparable he was rooting
for my real it was when he stepped in to
fight for the oh I know be when yeah the
first time we did the viewing party yeah
we were he's fast yes he was fighting
kabhi how do you know him we met on a
chat room but isn't a like kids is a
real estate agent why is he living with
Gabe I mean I think he I think he met
him and then and Alex is like do you
have a bathtub no games like hey you
know welcome to me has a bathtub I like
is like your small guy you want to live
with me yeah hey how about your how good
are you at being Jimmy Jimmy and Joey
Joey wasn't like if he got caught up on
some lines I don't think so we're gonna
try to get a line set up for that fight
and you apparently we're gonna be a
slight favorite really I don't see why
though I think lose the flame I think
he's big Judy's got look at his training
camp who do I have yeah well I think
you're trying to just skew this you got
I think miss Bing you've got warmer
chance goes to three different he goes
to an MMA school a grappling school and
then he has a boxing coach and he goes
and he's still going to a middle school
I didn't want to say it but I had two
slices of pizza when I was in New York
he's also like 40 pounds he doesn't have
a job and he probably won't make weight
he said if he does he look we're gonna
be weak making weight is I think a
disadvantage for him I thought he was
Charlie though in a way it was super
advanced that's how big he is
so I thought it was income talking him
up I'm sure yeah and he's got tattoos
that's scary yeah I thought he was in
calling me bad I think he was in that
video
he's the personal trainer of the guy who
code me back
he might be the new Jimmy oh that would
be yeah the J is for Jimmy it's Lu now
Jimmy his name is Jada James I believe
CEO Jim or Jitsu he said that he if he
loses he will suck big J's dick that's
not a win for anybody for big J you
don't want your friend to suck your
lights on no the lights on I'm not gay
I'm assuming it's his first Dick's mail
you know so it's not my first take Adam
Adam it's not his first really I think
you suck some guys dig on legion of
skanks legitimately
who did Lu know what is this shows way
crazier than I so who both why that's
why I didn't [ __ ] gigantic festivals
Rannazzisi got naked cuz he was
expecting a suck I've got a milk me do I
need a non trace I mean my house is like
a dairy farm
milking Oh get over here daddy needs to
be milked
Steve's living his life he's getting
milked all the time which is getting
milked at least he has a house over here
in Ostia I'm yodeling getting out my
prostate milk here's a family and you're
just an idiot um yes so I think lose the
favorite in this I mean look he's just
well we'll figure that out he's just
such a machine 18 podcasts Joe stamina
yeah he definitely done a lot of pods he
penny boards it's the form of
skateboarding we learned for children I
heard biz bangs keeping his good eye on
him I hit it I tell you because a lot of
people curious about it and I was when
we were in New York I hit up my what am
I probably I guess arguably best friend
in the world Mickey gall and I was like
hey off record like who do you think
because I know you know both guys very
well who do you thinks gonna win this
fight and uh radio silence he just was
like no comment he wants to stay out of
it yeah yeah and I would I would have
not told anybody what he said you would
I want to set it on air because I don't
want to people to skew the you
voting or how people gamble cuz I really
do want people to I think a mancine
louis strain yet - that could be a
possibility maybe maybe but I know
they're all good everyone's all good
friends though I'm excited for it Mickey
Taj Mahal Taj Mahal
I'm gonna call you yeah by the way did
you guys know I saw that Bruce Buffer
was on kill Tony did the interest he's
doing stand-up now I shot yeah that is
true the beach is that where I saw Tommy
magic no I saw his name on the flat I
think he was doing a show that Kareem
Matthews you know that guy great guy he
say he was on and I was you know and
because I follow him on Instagram and
and it was like boxers on it too and I'm
like is he doing stand-up or was he just
like he doing the boppers 360 when he
does punchlines I'm sure he'll get so
dizzy he gets at the crowds face he's
just screaming like he doesn't do the
fine I think this is the end of comedy
though cuz this is what happens always
people are like Oh comedies booming
right now it's just a good way to make
extra money so everybody get into it
yeah that's what happened the 80s and
the 90s bust yeah it was the same [ __ ] I
think all right we might be in a tail
end of this comedy boom I better like my
life good is in there I mean all these
guys are doing it I wrote Woodley yeah
there's an MMA and wrestling invasion in
stand-up yep there sure is I say the
will O'Neil and lures yeah exactly we're
covered or the other way we're the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that are only doing MMA
you're the salmon swimming water seeking
its level yeah I mean I expect MMA guys
to look at us like open my kurz like
these guys are going out there and try
to do an open mic you know should you
know was getting into pro wrestling is
what Cain Velasquez was training at the
WEF Center and Travis Brown is trying to
get in there because he's like I'm Owen
15 he's arresting women and Rhonda's in
there yeah wife yes he is so he Cain
won't get injured they're like what's
the problem no you got injured Josiah
walking to the Train
I always used to say that uh if you
could have a Andre the Giant wrestle
with a cane like he could have him in it
barely why he was [ __ ] in the back
of planes
who's the guy's fighter he's from
Chicago the snake Roberts no UFC guy
grita
no Clay Guida he's just bleed I got that
was great I was great and the first one
was a goof guess he was would be
bleeding on the way to the [ __ ] ring
we went to octagon we went to the league
premier party years ago with Steve I
tore my Catherine is easy and clay guida
was a bunch of them were in town it was
Sam stout Clay Guida John Jones Nate
Diaz Oh cowboy rode on he Cerrone Oh
dinosaur oh I miss his son danger really
it's pretty cool that's badass but the
first names like dachshund but he calls
him dachshund dangerous aroni but he
goes by danger that's a great name
that's pretty bad it was like I just
brought my baby home can't wait to teach
this [ __ ] so much [ __ ] when he
called into the show one time when we
were at the other before three studios
ago when we read toad hop yeah maybe my
time in the photo
Batman oh yeah right in there he was at
store the internet and I'm sorry yelling
at him I used to kill yourself to jump
into a river you're not living your life
but uh he called into the show he wasn't
into you but called in and we're like
hey what are you doing right now Cowboys
like man I was driving my truck drinking
a beer
literally amidst to drinking and driving
you grew up in Indiana yeah everybody my
dad had a beer here in his lap every
single time I was in the car with it
it's illegal not to leave them in the
back of the truck so if you ever got
pulled over they look back there'd be 40
empty beer cans in the bed I heard if
they pull you over there like sir
where's your beer we're gonna to write
you a check
you're driving a little too straight you
were constantly between the lines well
you're way too low you have to be at
least a point one zero you're under
you're the point away and he's out there
in the country man like you get away
with anything when I was a kid my uh
we've got a Notre Dame football games
but usually like the real expensive
games you would you know we couldn't let
get to where you're sleeping Jon Favreau
and Rudy pretty much so you go like that
thing called a blue and gold game as the
first game is basically a scrimmage and
tickets were super cheap to that so we
would go but you couldn't drink in a
stadium [ __ ] man I couldn't be seven
maybe I'm seven already drinking [ __ ]
fix it for a beer here I go the parking
lot have some class Fighting Irish do
you know I was the booze mule Chinese
stars oh you're these other diaper young
my dad my uncle would take okay we've
got to the car and then get two beers
and then roll the program around him and
then give that to the kid yeah so I want
to be holding these two beers and then
my dad and my uncle would get first as
we would walk in and they wouldn't frisk
the kid I'm just holding this program
and then we go in and they like get us
the program kid my dad had those
wraparound it would say like it said a
coca-cola would say like oh that Cola
from your sad son career to see here
keep moving
poopsie just h2o liquid doctor snapper
doctor snapper goes by the way I have
some now there's gonna few times around
like how does wrap these around the
throat I used the the plastic ones so
it's see-through I just drink out of a
brown drink out of like they're like sir
when you're 7up is brown I just use Red
Solo cups says soda yeah if it written
in marker I was so done when I was a kid
like yeah I had a public-house whatever
kind of sporting poster out it or
whatever football DOJ's Chicago boy
accent posers by Jordan post or whatever
and living in one house never thinking
like I would we would ever move around
ever to take that poster down so in my
own bedroom I would just light that
thing up with throwing stars because you
couldn't see that well four years later
we move and I take that poster down like
five years of [ __ ] it would be a cool
poster it's Bono's but it's Bono's hose
and there's Oh with a bunch of naked
chick I I never had sports posters I
only had cars I'd carve posters everyone
Lee had Jordan posters I had I had to I
had a lot of bo Jackson at Apollonia
poster I'm a lone ranger here from yeah
from Purple Rain oh that's Spencer's
gifts probably or something like that
Jim a Pam Anderson from Baywatch at a
buddy who had no I didn't have that that
was its tail's a class my buddy loved
her I'll do those were the best the old
80s posters with the chicks or of that I
mean you know like dogs you like go
through them like this they're all like
in a big rack songs I like but they were
like but they want to build kind of a
bathing so high but just regular thought
just take it off and that was the style
back then to have the [ __ ] sides of
it go up way above your hips what are
you [ __ ] magazine swimwear magazine
what do you thought [ __ ] weekly I'm
sorry to finish the clay guida story we
went from the oh yeah yeah we had to
walk from the premier to some like after
where was that it was at the ArcLight in
Holly okay yeah we had to walk just like
a few blocks but we beat we had already
live your life Shaffir introduce us to
them to help us live our lives yeah the
famous people of course we met here's
clay guida
meet him and then here's two round-trip
tickets to Austria Argentina where all
the Jews are Austria he's I you might
get in trouble there some of the Jew
haters are still around
probably but Clay Guida we like he like
got lost from everyone walked over kind
of in a group
and then he sauce he's like some
homeless guy just tried to fight me and
I told him I'll fight but I don't know
what you have so I can't he wanted to
fight the guy in the street played it
clay did yeah gray said he would fight
him alright was living his life and he
told me that he got picked up at the
airport in Chicago you have been Rogan
yeah and Rogan that's why and he's like
dude this guy was driving like a [ __ ]
madness also opened beer with a keg in
the back right to his mouth like one of
those camelbacks goodies he was driving
like a Buick or like an old man ya ya ya
ya [ __ ] Uncle Buck style without that
crazy suspension yeah you can fly over
those [ __ ] bums that is just like
floating yeah no power steering just
really crank and it went out like two
years ago
it's got like you know three gears on
the [ __ ] sit here I remember Mike
favor men Comedy Store comic no power
steering on his what was that car that
red Mustang oh the hardest time parking
that [ __ ]
oh the dude touch too tight turn you to
really crank Richards old car that we
caught up the sponge Jeff Richards car
was it but remember that convertible BMW
that he had yeah but he couldn't put the
top up
no yeah yeah he's lucky lived in LA well
yeah but still when it would rain it was
just still for like what days the seats
would be wet so he called the car the
sponge and one time I used to always had
this picture of my dick and balls cuz I
had it in my act where I'm like showing
a picture this and then finds out it's
my dick so I always had this and I like
was it opposed yeah I was like about
this big it was like a good [ __ ] and
nice days yeah hey you guys like prop
comedy that's when you were Jimmy then I
would show it and I go I know it's
thinking why am i showing you a picture
of my dick and balls and I fold up put
him in my thing I got no reason your
magician yeah yeah decided to do that so
I always had that army so I see the
sponge at the Grove parking lot
Richard's car uh and so I [ __ ] just
put it on the wind I'm like how can i
[ __ ] with his car so I just put it onto
the windshield so when he sits down it's
just my dick your boss it's like right
now
and then he calls me like a couple hours
a days it goes dude
you got me good but you also got my
grandmother good because that she just
looked held it and looked at it just
goes huh now I see how his grandma wants
to [ __ ] me yeah she thought it was a
parking ticket she's like wow they
really to granny
nobody didn't have another joke with the
same thing they more like a party joke
like I wouldn't do it on stage and I and
I would say and Bret Ernst love this
joke he'd always set it up to people
like at the store people around talked
and he's like Oh tell him who's
autograph you got and then I would go
into this long story of like oh [ __ ]
well first of all I'm a huge fan of this
guy I bump into him at a urinal at
Staples Center and couldn't be cooler
bigger then I thought he was gonna be in
person and but god I digress super cool
to sign it for me and then I'm [ __ ]
unfold it and it's just signed my dick
[Laughter]
the dr. Dre the more you could set up
the story about how yeah I read where I
bumped into the important meeting this
figure like the time dice rode the bus
wouldn't just wind you figure can you
believe the public bus may the dice man
think the baby classic baby behavior we
had an outfit just eat it and I saw a
wardrobe change nanny she smelled it
from the car to go outside oh yeah well
you know what the stereo still there I
hope do you guys have a sunroof did you
turn the heat up good smooth we're
trying to make her cut wait she's
fighting another baby coming up soon is
that true we ever in the car sweating it
off taking it to a playground in pound
that's one of the ideas that I had to
lay ground in time you want to see one
of the cutest things ever watch there's
this two or three year old in Thailand
and there
and he does Muay Thai and he's [ __ ]
leg kicking this adult it's unbelievable
I may get hurt and he's doing elbows and
[ __ ] really it is hilarity good yeah
he's a [ __ ] it's unbelievable
can we get it up here on the can we get
it on the Internet
Johnny where are you Johnny please if
you're if you're listening to me Johnny
sweet Johnny please answer my prayers we
need you son
right now he's like rushing to the
airport I know I got a little I'm just
looking at his computer helplessly I
know the link already uh yeah it's like
I think it's two-year-old Muay Thai or
Aaron or are you trying to do everything
and she's making phone calls Jesus oh
look it's Ari's [ __ ] just popped up
online I was a joke lookup giant [ __ ]
wait hold on gets what's coming to it
now yeah yeah it's like two-year-old
Muay Thai who you keep calling they keep
calling us we'll take off in a little
bit we'll take calls on a little bit
guys but I just wanted to say isn't the
show almost over it is almost over but
Aaron said we were gonna go to four okay
yeah that's cool so go to our good
friends Betty as I use the code
punch-drunk no no I'm sorry
punch 25 go to youtube and say we take
this call who is this let's take it
we'll take it could be re do it to it uh
hurt someone out there's not living the
life
user code punch 25 and that gives you 25
$3 to gamble with and what I'm highly
recommending is once we get these odds
up for the big rattlesnake versus the
Indiana Mongoose oh this isn't the one
this kids like a while oh I hope this
kid just kids kick right now lol yeah I
would fight that kid right now
well post it those kids will post it on
the Twitter no no this has a kid this
get other kids good this kid has no
coordination
he's got knocked out fry three-year-old
- OH - and a core year old okay here you
gotta get a call let's take one of these
calls let's take one each calls but
anyway I'm gonna get baby it's three
year old knows use the car these are all
white kids we need a legit tyke in is
this week [ __ ] you kid
we'll take the next call that comes in
no Aaron if you want used to coat upon
25 that get you 25 three bucks to gamble
with a target just service I searched at
the top three year-old Muay Thai kids
playing ping-pong now what I'm not
impressed with that no yeah
ping-pong four kids no kids for a lot of
videos of kid just search right at the
top of YouTube three-year-old yeah it's
great that kid no problem Gabe what are
the odds on this kid I think he's gonna
keep his hands up he's exposing himself
it's like his dick yeah it doesn't have
a chin basically so where are we gonna
take a phone call
yeah we'll take one if one comes in the
show yeah we got five minutes left all
back in is air conditioning behind
Rafael how you find it found it's right
here we should we should definitely had
two-year-olds fighting it ah this I'm
into this is what I call the playground
in pounds oh this kids on his bike come
on get in there there's a call hey get
in the dummy take it down you ready hey
come down to Chinatown here we go there
we go let's see what we got here
five five five this sounds like a sales
call oh yeah with punch-drunk what's up
you happy with your insurance provider
hey guys I was just wondering are you
guys gonna bring the Bushman to replace
Sam Tripoli that's a good question
though we could give a push man in here
to replace Bush man likes to party he
does like to party bush man like to talk
sports rock the blue would be great I
think we should have boot you guys know
yeah that I'm gonna get about forty
people to kick in 46 weeks to get the
damn fight oh [ __ ] wait for your math
you're pulling for O'Neal yeah where's
your course thank you sir
well thanks for callin bro appreciate it
enjoy the fight that's a smart man right
gonna go to Betty si.com user code punch
25 and throw it all on you good thing he
cleared his throat
yeah we started talking I know he almost
tore his ACL
yeah that's classic foot-in-mouth
disease now are you training today yes I
will it's hot out and I'd love to train
with it's hot it's good it's gonna be
[ __ ] nuts
today in tomorrow it's perfect for me
over a perfect training I live in your
life I have been drinking over a gallon
and a half with water or water is that
normal like I'm losing so much weight
really during training yeah I drink
almost a gallon during yesterday's two
hours what's weird is Lou ate a gallon
of ice cream yesterday and gained 15
pounds I thought I heard no damn it -
not making the weight and just be like
you know what I'm not gonna put myself
to it I'm gonna trade but I'm not gonna
worry about it that way pay them on I'll
just pay it I would try to walk in at
300 it's a [ __ ] move though especially
when you lose that weight I heard that
they're not even gonna have water
provided between the rounds form it's
just birthday cake yeah that's funny
Larry Bird was a wedding cake fan
remember that boxing thing they had the
[ __ ] speaking of favorite minute they
all did oh yeah I just saw it was on my
eye of DB credits recently I go wait
what the [ __ ] is a was smoking in
between rounds it was only 800 degrees
in that oh yeah oh my god that was
unbelievably hot a Davy Davy sweated out
his cerebral palsy I got so I fight
nanny and I gave Boone a ride home which
was just LaBrea and sunset where do you
want us to take you he's the brain son
so fine I see and he's in the back seat
and he did very well for even let him
sit up front maybe he was up front
did you tell I would what about work
because I would want to watch him and
see what the [ __ ] he's doing I would tie
him to the back of my grocery cart like
a reindeer that you have on the back
like national lampoon's vacation he had
a dog and boone de and he goes up I go
hey you know yeah who's in back seats I
was looking in the rearview mirror girl
hey just want to let you know you did
really good today like you should be
proud of yourself because I know that
was very difficult you did real good a
real good job and he goes in hindsight I
should have been a boxer never too late
booed live your life coming out there I
got had to fight another man with hey he
can't live his life because he could
told me that he can't get a passport
wait
said do why do you need a passport to go
to another country if Ellen and I go out
boy I know he did like 18 months oh
really
for $10,000 from a gas station wound up
in his presence he's a magician magician
do you know where I was coming but he's
like do you need why do you need a
passport because I'm gonna go to South
Africa Wow and I go well you need a
passport juice to get into any other
country what about Canada and I go yeah
that's another country you just don't
need a passport to get up there then how
do they people be sneaking into the
country without a passport
I go do they just sneak in and Boone get
into politics and he goes I'm gonna
stand I'm gonna sneak into somewhere I
go what are you gonna sneak into just I
think natural progression of questions
Australia 18-hour flight to Australia
and then landing and just be like I'm
sneaking in anybody need a didgeridoo
but then you don't see me no I could see
a paddling a bathtub across the ocean do
you need a boomerang you guys got
anything you want to plug any date Jenni
obviously your podcast obviously the big
fight though defy the podcast Danish no
Neil yeah I got a date with the girl
named Angela you should see the tits on
her she says she's a nothing the tits
are like sandy showers that was great
he's like did you [ __ ] my mom and my
sister bra how bad do you want to be in
the family you're in Holtzman stole this
also installed absolutely Zippo he
should be only a memorial speaker he
would be I would definitely like him to
be at mine
or a motivational he could warm up
Ferrari innovation I could see that
let's see take calls we did that oh dude
there's almost races maybe you've seen
this the most racist billboard now it's
the younger generation you know that one
with the bid the lips what a millionaire
what a yes I saw that it's unless wait
where is it they should have thought
that through it's on
Cienega which her what is she doing it's
her just laying on like a thousand
bananas natural habitat okay but I mean
with I mean what's it for though Banana
Republic I don't know what I do educate
her I think it's for her like makeup
line yeah but it's like her family's
weird yeah clearly all of them prefer to
date african-american gentleman nah I
don't I don't get [ __ ] maybe chose
something that's not inspire racist
thoughts they want that dude that chick
is about to be she's worth nine hundred
million dollars yeah and they say she
also made no not self made it all are
you kidding me can they're both self
that is yeah oh yeah they are all
trading off kim's big old [ __ ] yeah
Ray J the Ray J is he the one who [ __ ]
them all into Fame they're living their
life yeah and he doesn't get any of it
now
he was the guy who pulled out and then
[ __ ] blew his load right in her mouth
I watched it I haven't seen it and that
put her on the map got put on the map
well guys thank you for being a part of
the show right man he's taking care of
the baby in the back car but she says
goodbye yeah she actually had to come
out because it was so hot in there she's
get a little sweaty pull off in here
they go back and tend to the baby it's
hot in here as always subscribe to our
patreon subscribe to your guys's patreon
and go to all comedy t-shirts calm and
you can pick up any kind of punch-drunk
mercs that you would like there and
thanks to our good friends at that DSi
and all things comedy suck it live your
life